alright guys bangbang super excited to
have Mike on today a little bit
different in that I have no clue if he
knows anything about crypto but he's had
a fascinating life and a mutual friend
Grant great now is two for two with me
one he convinced me to switch the zoom
so we are now using zoom and can hear
each other and see each other and you
guys can listen to us and also he
connects with Mike so thanks for doing
this man I'm stoked to be here awesome
alright let's just go through your
background kind of what you did and how
the hell do you become a prolific skater
so yeah it was you know it felt a little
random because my intentions as a kid
was never to become a pro skateboarder I
just started skateboarding and fell in
love with it and it quickly became an
obsession of mine and I just didn't want
to stop it was like that simple I just
didn't want to let it go and when I you
know right around 16 my parents really
started pushing me to get a job and I
took that as taking away from time that
I wanted to skate so I had to figure out
a half around it which ended up being
you know convinced companies did give me
free products and then I don't need
money because I get it all for free and
and then that prolonged or gave me an
extra two years until I was gonna
graduate high school and then you know
my parents hit me with where are you
going to college and you know I wasn't
quite ready yet to give up skating so I
had to figure out a new plan and figure
out how to get these companies to pay me
and then that ended up turning into a
career was all out of you know
desperation of not wanting to stop doing
what I love doing so one of the things I
always think is fascinating especially
in sports like skateboarding how much of
it is you were good and then you found
sponsors versus you're able to find
sponsors who gave you gear which gave
you the opportunity to practice more and
like that led to you be good really how
do you think about that kind of balance
man I you know what I think I've seen it
all at this point truthfully there's
definitely like people who are just
god-given just spilling talent and they
are just naturally good you have those
people right
I was not one of them I I was the person
who became so obsessed that I wasn't
willing to not be good and I wasn't
willing to hear no I was more like the
workhorse guy and and that's just what I
had to do to create success because for
me it was a little harder like I was I
was the kid in my crew that took the
longest to do tricks I was the one that
everyone was waiting for I just wasn't
willing to give up and you know I had
other friends who it was just it was as
natural as walking it was just it was
like art watching them do it and so I
think it depends you usually land you
know if not on opposite and somewhere in
the middle and I just ended up leaning
towards I've got to work harder than the
people around me yeah I love that and
then what did you do in terms of your 16
year old kid and you say hey I gotta go
convince these brands so I give me here
what was that process like do you just
start cold calling people or what do you
do yeah it was a little harder back then
and it is now there's no social media so
basically I convinced that we had a
filmer like a neighborhood film er the
guy who just like filmed all of us and I
convinced him to help me make a video
kind of like a sponsor me tape and it
took about I don't know four or five
months to make it it was about three
minutes long it was BHS style and I just
went through the magazines and in every
once awhile when a company ran an ad
they would leave their address and so I
didn't care the company I would just I
was I took the address on any company
that left it and then package might be
just tape up wrote attention team
manager because I didn't even know
people in the industry and I sent like
40 of these things out just at will and
no one called me back it was just
completely dry and so I convinced the
guy who filmed Steve Ireland to make me
another tape took another four or five
months I send another 40 out and on the
second batch I got two companies to call
me okay and when you're sending these
out is there like a letter in there
that's basically like sponsor me or like
what goes with the tape there should
have been
limited experience Nomad it was a tape
on the tape I put a sticker that said
Mikey Taylor with my phone number under
it and then you know a package that said
attention team manager that was it it
was all I had it worked it worked it
worked it was like you know the greatest
than God like you guys snuck in there
somehow I loved it I loved it ensue I'm
assuming that at some point like once
you get sponsors does it kind of
compound and now oh you've got that
sponsor so somebody else wants to
sponsor you or do you still kinda have
to hustle for more sponsorship for those
first two you know what there's okay so
in skateboarding there's a thing called
flow which means companies just give you
free product but they're not advertising
you and then from the point of them
advertising you is when you become
amateur and then Pro is beyond that so
think of it as like three ranks right
the flow scenario was awesome because
we're getting free product but no other
company knows who you are you you
haven't made a splash yet so I didn't
have a lot of companies calling me at
that point it wasn't until I started
getting in magazines videos where then
people started paying attention me and
then other companies started reaching
out but from the point of me getting my
first sponsor man it was probably three
years from that point all right so every
skateboarder I know has incredibly crazy
stories of things that they tried to do
what's the craziest thing you can tell
us that you're comfortable being on the
internet that you and your friends try
to do skating like reckless stuff like
places that we try to see it that we
weren't allowed to sure that's a good
even sounds better oh man um you know
what's funny man we were kids like you
know like being where we weren't
supposed to be with such a regular
everyday occurrence and like running
from the cops was like so normal for us
I'm trying to think of like a point
where it all went wrong
and what you're basically saying that
everywhere you went you weren't supposed
to be Mike truthfully my job was an
illegal job I was never supposed to be
doing what I was supposed to do I mean
think about it man schools you're not
allowed to skate
Gulshan aloud seated business like the
amount of FI cards that have been
written on me or its books by now you
know it's just like a normal thing like
the cops in our area knew us by name it
was just part of the gig you know I'm
trying there were times where you know
we got tickets there was times gosh
there was one time and it wasn't even us
trying like do anything out of the
ordinary but we were skating in San
bernandino
we were skating at the school and it was
probably maybe 11:00 at night we used to
vote at schools that at night like stuff
up because no one was around and the
cops came right which is like totally
normal for us but like where we were was
a little bit hood and so the cops come
in like guns blazing right where there's
like ten of us were on the ground and
we're from like Thousand Oaks so we're
like suburb kids we're on the ground
hands like right and as they're running
our info they take me aside and they go
do you have something to tell us
I was like no and they're like are you
sure because we just ran in your name
and I was like no and he goes well put
you know put me handcuffed me and he's
like we're gonna arrest you and I was it
for what and I guess some guy out there
just got popped for armed robbery
had my same name same age like
freakishly aligned right and so they
thought I was a fugitive on the run and
like I'm sitting here on 18 years old
I'm basically in tears right I'm like
you guys don't understand up from the
suburbs like I live in this neighborhood
it's like the movies like you know just
totally green and and they're looking at
me like something doesn't add up
and I'm just like oh my god and my
brothers I'm like Matt call mom and dad
like they gotta get me out of here under
Ben arrest at that point so so basically
as they're getting ready to walk me out
I was like you know begging and please
can you please just run my name one more
time this is not me and he runs it one
more time and for some reason the person
on the the operator whatever it was like
said something like how tall is he
and they were like he's like six two and
I guess the guy would happen to be like
small he was at five seven right uh we
have all I don't know this is him and
then they ended up you know figuring out
if it wasn't me and then they let me go
but even when they let me go they didn't
even give me a sorry they're like you
guys should have not known better I was
gonna ask like as you're leaving are you
cordial with them or is this like I told
you you know you had the wrong guy the
whole time I was silent and just
thankful to get me the hell alright and
so as you guys are kind of growing up
like my understanding is as you're
talked about those tears right kind of
the flow and then even into the amateurs
like a lot of this is just you're doing
it because you love doing it at what
point does it become kind of a job right
not in the negative sense of a job but
just like you start realizing like oh
wait I can like make it living doing
this and it's not just to get 3-tier but
like they're gonna pay me money so two
point two parts to it one you start
making some money when you turn amateur
it's not a time but it's a little bit
then you turn prone you make a little
bit more and the challenge isn't you
love doing it so like any type of money
is like oh my gosh I'm getting paid for
my craft you're not making that much at
that point there there was a time in
which I got a my own signature shoe and
that's where like kind of more
significant money came in
and so from a monetary standpoint it was
right around oh gosh I was probably
twenty-three twenty-two twenty-three I
was like okay here we go
on the other end though you know when
you have a passion you just do it
because you love doing it right there's
no one telling you how to do it when to
do it
why to do it when you get sponsored you
all the sudden have to show up to demos
contests you have magazines etc and it
changes it definitely does there's an
adjustment and you almost have to like
like reinvent your passion for it if
that makes sense and then you have
expectations now you have people
watching you and criticizing you so it
kind of for me all aligned at one time
where I started making okay money and
started feeling the pressure was right
around that 23 22 23
time and then I was like okay this is a
job in this isn't it's fun anymore
you know I didn't like find a new a new
love it almost feels like to some degree
they're like oh hey by the way we're
giving you money because you have to do
things for us right I'm like that's
right that's right that was a very
valuable learning experience is they're
not just giving me money because I love
skateboarding they're giving me money
because they see some type of value in
which I can then make them money and so
it you know I had to learn that and then
and then through that I had to learn a
new way to like it you know it's like
that was just what was what we were up
against so that was like I don't know
three years in about okay and then in
terms of like the competitions versus
just skating more for fun like obviously
you're kind of always expressionistic
skateboarding it seems like always kind
of competing with yourself hey can I do
this trick can we do this whatever but
then you go into an environment where
there is the cameras there is fans like
all of that like how did that change in
terms of not the the money side of it
but actually like what you're actually
doing on a day to day basis so so for me
I didn't speak contest entire Boulder I
was Pro for probably ten years fry ski
at a contest and that's because of what
you just touched on it's I was drawn to
skating because it was me against me I
wasn't looking at the other person
trying to be better than them it was
like how can I improve who was such a I
mean it was selfish but it was
incredible how it was just about me
and so with skating even when I became
pro and other people pro it was all
about how I could shoot the best photo
in this magazine for myself once contest
came into the picture and this was gosh
I was probably 27 at this point which is
super late for a proto skate contest
that was the first time where I actually
had to like train and like practice and
like get my mind in the in the game in a
sense and there's parts I liked about it
there's parts I did it like one I'm
naturally a competitive person so there
was an element that I liked that side of
it the other challenge I had was I
didn't pick skateboarding because I
wanted to compete with the person next
to me so it was a there was a balance
behind it I guess pros and
- both but when I skated contest like
truthfully I would try to do the best I
could do and if that meant sixth place
and it was the best I skated I was
stoked if I skated like crap and got
third wasn't that happy on it and so
after your skate career you obviously
wanted to do other things but while you
were skating were you doing other things
kind of on the side or were you just a
hundred percent all of your time and
effort and mental energy focused on
skating so there was two parts of it the
first half of my career was 100% focused
on skateboarding but I was I was I was
investing a lot when I was young so I
had somebody come into my life that
started teaching me about money but I
wasn't managing anything other than
might focus on skateboarding but then he
kind of taught me how to be disciplined
with how I spent and then he kind of
educated me on where I could put money
and that was ultimately my back-up plan
like I'm gonna focus on skateboarding
I'm gonna make as much as I can here and
I'm gonna put as much of that to work so
that when my career ends
that'll be my exit it wasn't until gosh
how old was like 28 so this is a little
past halfway through I started wanting
to start my own companies and this kind
of entrepreneurial spirit came in and
that's when I kind of started this
hybrid approach where I was still a pro
skateboarder but I was trying to start
companies while I was still pro and
relevant and influential and then I did
that for oh gosh maybe six years and
then at 6-year point is when I stepped
away completely from skateboarding and
then went 100% into business and what
were some of the early business either
ideas or actual things that you started
in terms of why you were skating you
were trying to started these businesses
and work on them okay so I had this like
original idea that like anything that I
was gonna market I could own that was
like my first first idea and so you know
it started with like a backpack company
a skateboard brand a clothing brand we
started a craft brewery which ended up
being a huge blessing because I didn't
have a drink sponsor so was i cooking
cool like I don't have a drink sponsor
like that'll be a good
like whatever accessory brand almost and
then gosh also we did we did a design
company we did I tried to do a platform
one time like an artistic platform a lot
of those didn't work and then what I do
now okay and so when you go to start
like it makes sense right a lot of not
necessary professional athletes but a
lot of like content creators and stuff
now a real singer wait a second if the
advertising is valuable to the
advertiser like it's very valuable to me
too right like I should probably build
this stuff how are you going about you
know this is a couple years ago so it's
not like you know the Internet and kind
of all the tools we have today but when
you go to start that backpack company or
that skateboard company or whatever like
or you literally doing it by yourself
are you building teams are you trying to
use other tools like my just walk
through kind of like operationally how
you were trying to do it it's a good a
good question
so I I learned through experience the
importance of building a team and that
was because I was still skateboarding
right like that like I said I have a
point where I was still skateboarding
him strength start businesses and each
one demands so much time so the only way
you're able to do two things at once is
if you have people come together and
help you achieve both together and so
the first company I started and it's not
even the first the first shoe I had to
find people to help me operate them from
a day-to-day standpoint because I wasn't
able to dedicate that much time so how I
would do at the beginning was I would
spend a lot of time creating the company
helping create the team and launching it
and then once the point of launching it
then I was able to free up some time to
then put towards skateboarding and then
participate heavily on the marketing
side and then any of like the bigger
picture decisions and conversation and
then that led to which is awesome when I
started my next company when it was a
hundred percent business and no longer
skateboarding I was already trained that
I need people to
helped me create this vision I am it's
not possible for me to do it alone and
so that was a huge learning lesson that
I was fortunate to learn through this
hybrid model of me still skating and did
you were you one of the first skaters to
kind of say hey wait I can rather than
advertise somebody else's stuff I'll
just create my own or did you learn that
from somebody learned it so there was a
skateboarder called Jamie Thomas and he
was he was so implement influential to
me because one I saw him in a video one
time like he was filming one of the
skaters and he was like one of the
gnarliest best pro skateboarders of all
time and I saw him in a video filming
another skater I was like whoa this
guy's films also and then I found out
that he owned the company he rode for
which was zero and then he ended up
starting a shoe company called fallen
and he was the first example where I
went oh my gosh
theatres can be more than speeders they
could own the things they're doing and
so he was I think the first example that
I saw and then there were a handful of
others but truthfully not that many yeah
it's so fascinating and then in terms of
walking away from skating you pretty
much had spent sounds like almost 20
years of your life doing this maybe even
more why stop but was kind of the
impetus for saying all right maybe maybe
I shouldn't do this anymore so ok
remember I told you no one skateboarding
became a job for me
I had to find a new love in it so there
was a point where like whatever I love
skateboarding and then all the sudden
you know the pressure the requirements
there was a time where I didn't like it
anymore and I ended up falling in love
with the business side of my ski career
and that happened around the same time
to me getting a shoe and I started
experiencing you know everything that
goes into selling products sales
marketing you know it designed it was I
was fascinated by it
and once I got a first shoe then I
started looking at okay I can do tricks
but how can I reach more people what
platforms can I get on to grow my
audience and and how can i connect with
them that is then in turn gonna help me
sell more product and I started loving
that process and then even when I
started
first company it just started
reinforcing this new passion that I
enjoy building something and so with
with my skateboarding and why it ended
up ending
I had my sponsors had two sponsors that
were my main income ended up letting me
go and it was at a point where I had
just had surgery and so I was laying on
the couch got a call all of my income
went away and I was probably I don't
know 12 months maybe 11 months away from
being a hundred percent being recovered
a hundred percent and so I kind of had
to make a decision it was like okay I'm
34 years old
I have passion for for the business side
I can't skateboard for another year I
have no income coming in what are my
options and I looked at it as my options
were I can he'll try to get more
sponsors and maybe I'm two years out
possibly from making money again as a
pro skateboarder or I use this time as
as the time to truly step away and I
looked at it as there was even if I
tried to get sponsored again
I was only trying to delay the
inevitable because there's only a so
there's only long have so much time for
sponsors to pay me and so I ended up
stepping away and it was brutal
it wasn't easy it was it was it was such
a hard decision because I expected my
career to end a certain way and it ended
such a different way and I think all of
us naturally wanna we want things happen
on our terms and it didn't and there was
a point where I had to wrestle with that
and then ultimately accept it but that's
ultimately why because it no longer
became a career and then I lost the new
purpose I had in skateboarding because
now the business element wasn't there
either yeah and before we get into what
you did after your skate career
do you still skate and how often I still
skate not like I you I mean I when I say
I was obsessed even as a pro I would
skate five hours a day every single day
for probably twenty something years like
thousands and thousands and thousands of
hours now I don't know once a week maybe
once every two weeks I mean for the
average person that's definitely a lot
right for the average I would say for
the average 36 year-old who has three
kids and a business days doing full-time
that's a pretty good amount and you
mentioned via the craft breweries so I
have on good order from grant that you
are gluten intolerant yet you started at
craft breweries so we're gonna have to
unpack this a little bit what's going on
there so when we started it I didn't
know I was gluten intolerant and you
know me and my two partners when we
started it we were like you know there
was an owner like
free beer forever like our you know our
fridge is gonna be stocked and three
months before we open doors I found out
I was going intolerant and it was like
the lights went dark I'm like are you
kidding me with this whole thing you
know so basically for three years we
owned it for a little over three years
you know we would do like we would do
events at the brewery and we would pour
beer I'd have to like take a signature
here and dia and fill it with something
else it was like it's such that part
sucked and then we end up we ended up
selling it and uh about a year and a
half two years later they they did a
group free beer I was like we really
should have been on that trend we had it
you know I love just the idea of you
know you hear always he was like oh
follow your passionate I've literally
heard people say if you tell that to too
many young guys they literally go create
beer companies and like all this stuff
right like oh I like to drink I was
creative Peter company finally you gotta
work with passion it worked right yeah
so there's tons of you move crate of
breweries especially last couple of
years why do you guys end up being
successful and you also may sold it to
Miller Coors I believe right it's like
how do you end up building a successful
brewery where many are just not as
successful or end up not making it work
okay I'll tell you why I think it was
successful when when we started doing
our let's call it due diligence of
trying to figure out how to take this
idea and create it into a reality it was
two things were happening one craft beer
was starting to become mainstream
it wasn't popping like it is now but you
know there was a party you'd see two
people come up with a craft beer and
then it was still predominantly
you know Coronas and Miller and
Budweiser so we saw the trend happening
so there was timing on our side also
what we saw when we looked at at the
shelves there was no bringin there was
no vibe there was no feeling there was
no there was nothing done from a
marketing standpoint to connect with an
audience to make the audience feel like
they were a part of this company this is
this company represented who they were
and that in skateboarding is what
were built on it's like when you look at
vans or adidas or Nike there's no
difference in the shoes at all right
it's all the image and vibe and emotion
that they connect to their audience with
they get somebody to be a die-hard Nike
fan or a die-hard
adidas fan same thing goes for Chevy
Ford right and so we saw that as an
absence to the craft beer industry that
wasn't happening so you take an industry
that knows all about marketing and
having to differentiate product with
with content in an industry that is
up-and-coming it doesn't have any of it
so we were like dude what if we mark it
the way we know how to market in our
world right like let's let's let's sell
this California lifestyle surf skate
snow music this culture that we're a
part of in an industry where it doesn't
exist in and it was right at the time
where social media really started
popping like you started to have this is
before influencer marketing but it was
right like Instagram was like kind of
cracking and so when we started the
company we had to raise money for it and
so we hit up a lot of our friends it was
like mainly a friends and family rounded
that was pro surfers pro skiers
snowboarders and so when we were about
to launch you know we looked at it when
dude a lot of us have a following on
Instagram like what if we just post
about Saint Archer on Instagram and so
you take this perfect combination right
craft beer expanding not really any
marketing or brand building and craft
beer and Instagram and influencer
marketing ahead of its time and the
thing just you know it was it just it
was the right thing at the right time
and that's what I think did well and so
the original aspiration sounds like hey
where's our beer company let's raise
some money and we'll kind of a brewery
it would be cool whatever and then like
at what point is there this inflection
point where it's like oh [ __ ] like a big
beer company is gonna come buy this
thing and maybe they're calling inbound
or like at what point does it almost
become real that like this isn't just
like me and my friends have a brewery
this is actually a company that's gonna
acquire okay so when we went out to
raise money at that time me Paul and
Josh the three co-founders we didn't
know how to raise money and in that
process remember I told you I had
somebody come into my life that taught
me about money when we had this idea we
brought it to him and we're like what do
we need to do we didn't know what a
business plan was we didn't know
anything and so one he helped us build a
business plan but two he taught us
basically how to raise money and in that
process that was actually when it
switched and we had to figure out what
is the game plan here right and when you
raise money the first thing an investor
asks you where they should ask you is
how do I get paid back how do I make
money and not only do you have to tell
them you have to paint the picture in
which they think it's actually possible
then it's gonna happen so we had to
accept when we were pitching this thing
yeah we had to sell it and this thing
had to be successful for you for anyone
else to make money so so we understood
that that was there then when we opened
doors it was really apparent right when
we started that we had something special
I mean it was you know with other
companies I've done it didn't work like
saying Archer it was like we're gonna
break through we're gonna break through
we're gonna break through and then like
year three it's like oh we've got some
traction here with Saint Archer the
second we open doors we couldn't keep up
we could not keep up it was it was we
are falling short of demand over and
over and over and our challenge for
three nap years was how do we grow fast
enough to meet the man so it was it was
different than the other ones I've done
yeah but you had the experience to kind
of fall back and compare it to and then
how does the MillerCoors deal come
together they call you guys you guys
call them like how does that work we had
a call like the broker or an investment
banker reach out to us that represented
big brands for big big companies that
we're looking to acquire smaller brands
and they reached out to us and asked if
we were interested and and then
basically you know we're like hey we'll
listen and then that turned into multi
offers and then it was like oh crap this
actually could be something and then it
was like you know throughout the process
even after we sign the documents we
didn't think it was real and it all the
sudden the wire comes are like normally
I ask whatever a billionaire comes on I
go what did you do when you became a
billionaire but the day the second you
became and realize you're a billionaire
what did you do for you guys selling up
business is a very similar kind of
euphoric moment right where's not just
personal net worth it's like oh we built
something together as a team and we just
sold it wire hits what's the first thing
you do so yes I didn't become a
billionaire but I became a millionaire
and it scared me it was such a different
experience than I thought it was gonna
be in Paul one of my closest friends who
I grew up skating with one of the Great
Escape was all time was one of the
co-founders as well and we both got the
why don't we saw each other the next day
and we both of the same feeling it was
like oh my gosh like we really can't
blow this now like we have to like
really be smart and it was like it was
so differently we thought it was gonna
be like you know partying and toast and
dude not the case so basically my wife
and I this was months after we sold it
my wife was like hey you know it
we don't ever celebrate much we should
celebrate
I think you know we sold the company and
so her and I went to Mastro's and had
dinner that was it you know I'm just
different it's totally different well
listen I know you're telling the truth
because literally every single person
thinks oh when I saw my company
literally you know we're to go pop
bottles at the club and it's gonna be
this amazing thing and it's say you're
sitting there like oh Sh
it like we can't mess this up dude and
you know what and I was still
skateboarding might happen so it was
like there was a part of me that was
like [ __ ] everyone knows and like dude I
you know I went to a demo I remember
going to this demo and this this guy was
like on the mic or whatever and I skate
anything Mikey Taylor news millionaire
sold sit and I'm just like oh my gosh
like skaters don't talk about this stuff
don't talk about money I remember being
so embarrassed so there was a plane that
like it was just I felt I was
embarrassed I was quiet about it I was
uncomfortable it took me a while to like
be okay with like what we did and
actually be proud of it yeah and another
thing is you had money from family and
friends
what's their reaction I think a lot of
people talk about like what was your
reaction when you finally say to them
hey we're selling this thing here's the
price and for everyone who get you know
for every $1 you gave us here's how many
you're getting back what was that
conversation like so that was where the
joy was it was so much more fun that
experience than personal and not saying
like we weren't blessed by it we were
blessed by it but like dude my dad my
father-in-law like do my dad paid off
his house because of this it was like my
father-in-law was like these are guys
who like like my dad and my
father-in-law they gave me money because
it was me like they I think they
expected it to not pan out and gave me
what they could afford to lose you know
and like to see that like bless them was
like I mean dude it was like dude that
was crying like that wasn't say my uncle
was an investor like this is my family
right and then it was like dude there
were ten pro skateboarders that were
invested these are like my friends and
like to see them like if that was the
best part of the whole thing you know
and a lot of these guys like you know I
was fortunate enough to have somebody
help me learn about investing prior to
that moment so I had experience with
investing I never had a gain like that
but I had experience with it a lot of
this keyboards is the first time they
invested anything so it was like it was
just to see the lightbulb Gothika this
is I need to be here you know though I
downsized then they think everyone's
gonna do that right what's the next one
up so that's the problem with your first
time at bat hitting a grand slam you
think you're gonna hit him every time
after then you started hitting you know
balls out it's a challenge well so I
don't know if you know who Pat McAfee is
Pat was a NFL player I was punter in the
NFL for a number of years and he
recently kind of left that really the
height of his career trip now millions
at
and goes and star student content on the
internet everyone's you know literally
element screaming like what are you
doing you're an idiot right and long
story short is I guess they're a couple
iterations but he just signed this
massive deal with FanDuel so they're
gonna sponsor him and all this crazy
stuff but he's got a group of 10 guys I
think it's nine or ten guys who are like
his team right so they help moving
production to guest all this stuff and
he just put a video up on the internet
where he takes five hundred thousand
dollars and he goes to the bank and gets
it in cash he's got backpacks and he
puts 50k in each backpack and then he
goes at night he's living like a
sleeveless shirt and like some stupid
like jean shorts that are real short and
he goes to every single person's house
he's like on the phones like yo dude
come outside yo yo where are you my guys
are coming the door like their boxers
and stuff you know I almost crazy stuff
and he hands in the backpack and they
open it they reach in and they're like
dude 50 K like what are you talking on
there
and you see the reaction and they're
just like because I bet on this guy I
bet on my friend I've been working with
them like like game on right and these
dudes are hype and so it's like that's
just for investing your time when you
take that financial risk right and then
you get the reward it's like that on
steroids
yeah oh yeah yeah that's amazing that's
such a cool story yeah I think you it's
like it shows to like where where we get
joy from it's like we we focus so much
on ourselves but like the true joy comes
when you do things for other people like
give me I mean you know I money is just
one of those things like I don't think
you should worship money but people get
really stoked on money so seeing that is
for it is cool you know what's the
saying money doesn't solve all your
problems but it solves all your money
problems right all right so so another
thing is you today have a very positive
mindset but I also heard that you are a
little bit of a head case back in the
day in terms of every skateboarder
pretty much when they're young super
frustrated can't land a trick like all
stuff like how do you over the years
mature kind of shift that into a more
positive mindset and like really start
to believe hey I can build companies I
can you know invest capital and start to
trust
yourself really a there's gonna be two
answers to that because they happen in
two different ways
the point about my temper and being
frustrated and that was that not bad for
a point there there was a there was a
moment I'm this is when I knew it got
really bad I ran out of boards so
typically think your sponsor sends you
like ten skateboards a month and I ran
out of them and so I went to a skate
shop and I was like hey I need to get a
couple boards I'll bring me back a board
when you know I get them and I get this
board I set it up I looked down and it
wasn't the right shape I put my foot
through the board focused a brand new
board at a skate shop right you know go
pick out another board set it up do the
same thing foot through the board right
set up my third board so you can imagine
this guy goes into a skate shop sets up
two brand new boards puts his foot
through third one put my foot through it
walk down to the storm so heated right
and Blake who's grants brother who
connected us you know he hits in the car
and he's silent I'm pissed off
and he looks at me goes well upset there
buddy like Blake you have no idea he was
like kind of the first one I was like
dude you know I think you need to check
yourself and then it was like not long
after that I had a night basically where
I was at one of my sponsors Christmas
parties and I was walking back to the
hotel like 2:00 in the morning and I
just had this moment where I started
thinking about myself about my life and
it was it was this really trippy
experience but basically like I started
thinking about who I was and I remember
the the feeling I had was disappointed
it was like I don't like Who I am and
this isn't who I'm supposed to be I'm
not supposed to be this pissed off guy
who's complaining about everything who
takes all of this for granted like
that's not one supposed to be and and
there was this moment I had where it was
like I have to change like if I don't
change I'm gonna be miserable forever
and and so that night became the
beginning of transformation with myself
of just working on being more positive
working on being thankful and that was a
slow process then too
so the other question about having how
did I get confidence to be able to do
companies or invest that all came from
skateboarding that was like with
skateboarding you know I think it's the
hardest thing you can do on this planet
it takes so much time and dedication to
learn it but it builds so much
confidence once you do because you you
see the blessing of you dedicating all
of this time and energy delaying
gratification for sometimes months until
you get to experience it one time and so
I think that just built this confidence
in myself where I felt like I can do
anything and and it was like yeah if I
became a pro skier or like why can't I
start a business like I just be willing
to put in the time and so I would say
both experiences came from skateboarding
yeah that's an awesome answer and what
things do you say that was interesting
was this idea of like I'm not supposed
to be this way writer this is not who
I'm supposed to be it's almost like it
feels like you have like a self
evaluation but from outside of your body
and and there's other people who have
talked about you know Jeff Bezos is
famous for saying when I go to make a
decision I basically go to me at 80 and
I look back and I say which decision
should I have made right and that's kind
of one I go with like what was it that
drove you to cut almost had this image
of like who you were supposed to be it's
good question
at the moment at the moment it felt like
god truthfully it felt like it felt like
he was looking down at me and going I
didn't create you for this and it was
like I was sitting alongside looking at
the conversation happening it was the
weirdest thing and it's the first time
I've experienced something like that and
and so I think it was just seeing this
idea that like I was created to be
something I was created for this purpose
and I wasn't living up to that purpose
and it was like I guess you could use
the basis example it's almost like I got
this vision of what I was gonna be at 60
if I stayed on this path and then I got
this vision of what I was supposed to be
and I was not heading in the direction
of where I was supposed to be you know
and it scared me it was
and how do you change right so it's one
thing to say like hey I'm going down a
path I don't want to go down but that's
only like the analysis part the inertia
it's like change and so that's not very
easy for a lot of people like what did
you do or how did you figure that out
that's so I started with one thing it
was very small in the beginning but I
was having this from complaining about
everything so I told myself in the
beginning every single day I'm gonna
find one positivity in something that
feels bad something that happens that
I'm angry about I'm gonna find one
positivity in it and it became a game at
the beginning in like you know look you
don't change overnight this is I mean
truthfully from that point of me
deciding that that was pretty much mm I
don't know sevenish I'm still working on
it today so remember there's gonna be
grace to this but my first thing was
just I need to start finding the
positive the bad situations and so when
something would happen that I'd be
pissed about I would stop and go what's
good in here what could be good in this
situation and dude sometimes I had to
reach sometimes like I had to find
something that like was it very positive
I just had to ghosts anywhere to make
you know a good thing out of it and then
what ends up happening is it starts
becoming your routine to think this way
all the sudden you don't fight having to
find the positivity positivity soon
later all you see is the positivity and
even when bad things happen like for
example prior to me working on this
something bad would happen and initially
pissed off initially fired up right and
then I'd have to like fight for the good
in it then after I started working on it
bad things would happen and I wouldn't
even have that original like anger
feeling it was like okay that didn't
work out like I wanted it to what's good
out of this what could I learn out of it
and then it just became normal so I
would say that's where it started and
then from there I spent a lot of time
working on not being selfish that was a
big thing for me it's like I was always
thinking about myself and not others and
I found that once I started thinking
about others first that brought more joy
into my life so
it's funny minutes a lot of the things
that I think we're supposed to harness
kids and I just forgot about from being
I think in an environment like pro
skateboarding that was all about myself
yeah that's a fantastic answer and then
how do you eventually get to what you're
doing today with commune capital and
kind of the investing side like where
does that come from
so when my career ended and again like I
was I just had surgery right and for
anyone who has had surgery before that's
an athlete it's a mental battle it's
like being in war and gear you know what
I take that back basically what the
whole world is dealing with right now
because of co vid
that's what surgery feels like it's like
your mind is slipping away and you're
trying as hard as you can to bring your
mind back to where it's supposed to be
that's what that's what surgery's like
for Nathalie do you go through this
process of your mind telling you you're
never gonna skate again everything's
over you suck up a block and so I was
already dealing with that and then my
career ends and now that it's on top of
it like oh my gosh now what and in that
moment of me trying to figure out what I
was gonna do next which was about a six
or seven month process I was trying to
find out I was trying to find my
identity and I was trying to find my
purpose and I was wrapping that into a
company I had this idea that if I
started the company the company and me
being the business owner of the company
was gonna be my identity and my purpose
and I was failing miserably every idea I
had was not the right idea
and in that process I had a one of my
friends and that a pro skateboarder
calling me and kind of just check in on
me dude I haven't seen you in months
like what's your deal
and I was just really kind of beat down
and open with him and just told him like
dude I'm struggling like I don't know
who I am I don't know what I'm supposed
to do like this is the first time in my
life I felt depressed and it's felt dark
and you know he was like dude I don't
know why you're trippin like you don't
have to work dude like what are you
talking about you're like one of three
pro skateboarders it like doesn't have
to like call his sponsor up and say can
I please work in the warehouse and move
straight to survival mode what are you
talking about and it was like that
conversation that like
you know really made me feel like [ __ ]
and so I sat down on the couch and just
had this moment of like you know like
looking back in my life and going why am
I in this position like why am i one of
three and why was my friend like so
impressed that I was able to cheat that
but the majority of us can't and it all
went back to Randy who I met when I was
younger that helped me structure my
finance that helped me and Josh and Paul
start saying Archer and so my idea was
you know what I need to do what he did
for me
- all of my friends are so skateboarding
like I want all of my friends to be in
this scenario that I'm in because this
is something that would've been taught
to me if it wasn't for him and I would
be in the same snare as everyone else
basically out of money and scrambling to
find a job after my career if he would
have come into my life and so it started
us how can I get back and as I went
through the last 15 years he started off
with the foundation of finance he taught
me the very first steps of how to manage
my money and then he taught me about
investing and then he had opportunities
for me to invest with him which were in
real estate and so I basically tried to
replicate that model I created a company
that is a real estate fund so that's the
opportunity and then all of our content
is geared around educating the way he
educated me so it was all this give back
from what he did in my life when I was
20 21 years old yeah it's it's so cool
to to see I think athletes across all
sports really starting to understand
wait a second like we've always relied
on financial advisers and all these
other people who you know sometimes have
good intentions sometimes don't and we
hear the horror stories all the time but
it just seems like whether it's NBA
players sells like professional skaters
whoever they're just taking more kind of
personal responsibility and realizing
like hey I gotta I gotta understand this
stuff right I got to invest capital for
myself because if I just trust everybody
else I don't know what's going on like
odds are I'm gonna get screwed somehow
right that's true 100% that goes beyond
that lates that's the most people most
people that have advisors don't pay
attention to any of their money ever
they just this isn't my thing
there you go and
we shouldn't do that even if even if
money isn't our strong point we still
need to be educated on what our money is
doing because we work so hard for it how
are we gonna spend our entire lives
building up money and then not knowing
where it's going it's we just can't do
that anymore you know yeah and why focus
on real estate what was that just
something that you felt like you knew
and had an advantage with or what so so
I had experience investing a lot of
things now right it was like I was
investing in real estate and it was on
the commercial side storage units
multifamily I had experience in stocks
bonds and from a toilet investing in
startups the whole nine right and if you
looked at my portfolio and what I felt
the most comfortable in as far as risk
real estate was always that I feel good
with this like I feel like I can put the
majority of my capital to use and I
don't know if it was it being a tangible
asset
my dad had rental properties growing up
I don't know if I just had a liking
towards real estate because of what I
saw but I always felt more comfortable
with it and never felt like like the
stock market for example right the stock
market like I could never wrap my head
around why it was doing the things that
was doing but real estate felt like I
could it didn't have these crazy swings
so I felt good with that with startups
and while I'll go to San Archer when we
did Saint Archer and I think most
startups you have to be prepared to lose
everything it's a different type of risk
right so we're either losing your money
or we're gonna make a big profit and so
when you have that much risk you can
only invest or you only should invest an
amount that you're okay
losing you have to make sure you have
the capacity to lose that investment
right and so when I thought about how I
was gonna help athletes prepare for the
future it wasn't these crazy high risk
scenarios it was how can I create an
opportunity for them that is actually
gonna give them cash flow and
appreciation and something they could
live off of and I felt like out of all
of the investments real estate was the
thing that I felt the most comfortable
with and so now that I'm going out
raising money I wanted to do the same
thing that I was I wanted to put my
mount for my money with was and my money
was in real estate
and so that's really why I focused on
real estate yeah make sense and what was
like the initial reaction from skaters
and other people that you kind of went
to that were in your friend circle when
you're like hey look this what I'm gonna
go do and and you got to get educated
about this do they kind of fight you on
it or was it just hey that's the guy who
really understands this stuff so I trust
them so from my initial circle it
it was actually kind of natural most of
my friends kind of understood it and
that's because for my circle like I was
kind of the guy who like for example me
and the guy who called me asking if I
was okay right his name was Shawn
we went and basically were a part of
this rebuild for this shoe company
called etnies and it was me
all of our friends I was like the skater
that all of them looked up to and went
okay you helped them build this thing
we're just gonna skate so I already
created this relationship where they
were like you understand what's going on
you're interested in it we trust you
that you can kind of speak for us and
then with saint archer a lot of my
friends were involved in that and so the
next thing it was like you you're like
you're a friend but like do you kind of
bend this guy first the whole time like
we trust you and and we're in it it was
the rest of the industry that was a
little bit how would I say this they
didn't catch when it could you know what
causes them to eventually catch on us
they just see that it's working and
people are getting kind of those monthly
checks or lately what come is the
tipping party will so say hey you know
what actually like I may have laughed at
that or ignored it in the beginning but
like I actually should be paying
attention to this maybe I should be
participating I think because I had like
I had such a big transition like we
talked in the beginning about
reinventing yourself I had such a big
reach in tension right that in the
beginning I think a lot of people just
go the hell's he talking about and is
this gonna fade right and I think leads
because like we're we had one thing as
our identity and then that goes away a
lot of times we grab really quickly on
to the next thing it's like when you
hear about relationships and if you're a
guy and you know a girl breaks up you
jump into another one really quick right
in
so I think a lot of the people are like
what's he doing now what is this and is
this just a phase and is what he's
saying even true and then after a while
I think you hit a point where they go oh
wait a minute like this isn't just a
phase like this is he actually is doing
this in how does he know these things
and then you get to a point where they
start doing your their due diligence on
you they start paying attention and then
after a while it's like we're here man
how do we do this how do we get started
and and so dude it just took it took
time it's still taking time there's
still a lot of skaters that do not
approve what I'm doing for sure but
there's a group that's trying to like be
pretty encouraging now yeah and do you
see kind of non skaters kind of more of
the traditional investors wanting to be
in and around and associated with the
skaters and the skaters also like
they're like hey I'm a skater but like I
kind of want to know what the rich
people are doing so that I can learn
what they're doing and you kind of when
we get those two groups coming together
okay so yes believe it or not like if
you look at our investors dude it's an
eclectic group now like they are
diversified right it's like we have
skaters football players like we have
the athletes and then we have
entrepreneurs that like kind of I
connected with through like what I do
now and do we have lawyers a lot of
sales guys business owners like advisors
like it's a it's like traditional and
you know my kind of past life combined
and I think you have two sides of it
right like on the more traditional and
like do we have investors are a little
older now too right
it's like yeah they want to like be in
this like cool hip like Skeeter thing
but like they don't want to put their
dollars at risk either right they're not
just gonna hand me you know 300 grand
and go I'm just gonna give you this
because I want to be cool
right so there has to be a balance
between oh what are these guys doing and
this sounds cool and they know what
they're doing and I trust them with it
with my money so there is that balance
right and then from the skaters or the
athletes I don't know if they're so
concerned about being involved with like
traditional and but I don't know if it
I don't see that I think they're more
how do I learn about this and does this
work you know and then as it starts
working then it's like holy crap like
you weren't lying what else do I need to
know about this yeah do you ever bring
the whole group together like is there
like Christmas parties where you've got
the skaters and like the lawyers hanging
out together so we do like I have we
haven't got the whole group together yet
we do like we do do like like for our
content for example we build these
videos kind of highlighting individuals
that are investors with us we'll do
these conversation pieces with athletes
talking about money and then
unfortunately and what we talked about
with your wedding
we had it planned to do this event like
for all of us and then COBIT hit and now
we're gonna wait until sometime next
year so yes that that has been part of
our plan it's just it's taken time and
then now it's been delayed I love it
one of the last things I wanna talk
about it's just the real estate market
in general like how do you see that
changing given kind of Cove in the
economic shock and all of that it's
gonna change I'm for sure the thing
about real estate is
there's a lot of different assets in
real estate there's not just one thing
right so you have hospitality you have
single-family multi-family you have
retail you have storage of office all of
these things are gonna be affected
differently because of this right and so
you know I think we saw what happened to
hotels that was like the one that got
the biggest blow early on what happens
from that I personally think it's more
of a short-term problem as far as hotels
go again everybody's kind of speculating
at this point retail as far as stores
though I feel like this was you know the
last econ boom that that was like a
massive blow to retail I think this is
this could be like the the knockout and
so I think retail could change
significantly but even if you don't have
a physical store and you're selling
everything online you got to be able to
place this product somewhere so you know
we'll warehouse or industrial do well
through this I could see it doing well
office space if you would ask me six
weeks ago I would have said office space
is gonna get [ __ ] on
I don't know now actually part of me is
you know and I'm basing this off with
personal experience like it was cool
working at home the first like six weeks
so like yeah I'm doing this thing I am
sick of it now I want to get back in the
office it's like that's just me so I'm
wondering if that changes we'll see as
far as multifamily multifamily
single-family there there will be an
effect at some point we're not seeing it
the way we initially thought and I think
that's one of two things but right now
government is involved they're involved
with our business they're involved in
real estate and so I think the bigger
effect is gonna be because of that right
it's like we'll see how that shakes out
I like multifamily through this I like
storage through this but we will see
what's interesting right now what's
happening like at the moment is there's
invest investors are eager to invest
right as far as like dollars coming in
like they know that there's action to be
had
I think everybody's kind of feeling like
this is gonna be a big wealth building
opportunity they're eager
to invest deal flow is very challenging
right now and basically what you're
having is you have sellers that look at
uncertainty and they want to let go but
they don't want to accept the fact that
there's a post Co bid price correction
right and so then you're pliers like
this and we're going and that that price
has to come down like this is our time
now like right this is a buyers market
like you know you're not gonna drop
below 10% what are you talking about no
and so you have this sellers haven't
adjusted yet and buyers aren't moving
forward and so you know it's eventually
gonna do something like this but dude
there's not a lot of deals penciling out
right now so I've heard that from a lot
of real estate investors where they're
basically saying that sellers are still
holding onto pre-pandemic prices and
buyers are like chomping at the bit the
buyers are also being somewhat
disciplined understanding that the world
is different now but I was talking to
one guy and he had a really interesting
thesis he said I'm going after grocery
anchored real estate and warehouses
right and he was just like look
ecommerce boom like we're not going back
people realized that when they press the
button on the internet like the package
does show up and it's awesome so like
that's you know gonna accelerate and he
so I can look around like literally in a
pandemic we talked about pandemic
resistant type businesses he's like
what's the one business on every block
that didn't get shut down by the
government just grocery stores right and
he was just like that's going to you
know be a huge focus for moving forward
and I was like it's pretty interesting
to start thinking about like the
strategies changed as well right so it's
not just asset allocation hey should I
be in real say should I not but also
like a good types of people of real said
that people are looking for has seemed
to shift it as well a hundred percent
and one thing about it like even though
like this pandemic was kind of a Black
Swan that caught everybody kind of
blindsided us in a sense this naturally
happens through Corrections right risk
appetite changes strategies change and
people tend to be less opportunistic
right it's like dude January came around
people wanted huge returns right they
were willing to take on crazy risk and
wanted you know double-digit IRR
etcetera
now it's like where can I get 6% cash
flow that's more yield start now right
so investor appetite change yes like it
as far as what's gonna happen moving
forward you of course you have to change
I mean investing is still especially
something like multifamily it still
operates like a business right where did
the trends end where do the trends head
what's gonna happen are people are
people gonna want more space some of
these tiny homes gonna be less valuable
because we all experience what it feels
like to be locked in a house for three
months possibly hey what's the outcome
from it but it's like I'm a big believer
in people need a place to live they'll
always need a place to live and as long
as you're buying correctly to withstand
Corrections you'll be fine and so that's
what you're seeing now it's like you
have buyers that are going I'm not
catching the knife I know what's about
to happen I know where we're headed I
don't care if you don't know I know and
I could be patient right so it's it's
just a patience game at this point but
what is cool is in January when we put
offers in on apartments do their b-78
buyers like trying to get a deal below
asking was incredibly hard it's people
were jacking at the price now when we're
losing offers dude we're like the only
offer in maybe another group and it's
well below asking so it's just a matter
of time is my belief yeah last question
on that topic is just when does it
happen is this are you talking six
months until sellers realize three
months a year like what do you think
kind of but not to see the futures hard
to predict well so uncertainty is
everything right and you see it even
happening like in our lives like when it
looked like the economy was opening up
things were kind of starting to get
better it was like okay we've hit the
bottom and now we can adjust for it and
move forward until that happens they're
still gonna be uncertainty right and so
the question I think becomes at what
point can people no longer hold
distressed assets at what point are they
gonna be forced to take or exit a deal
that they don't want to exit and that is
when I think you're gonna start
seeing a price correction and look if
people if there's a rent if there's an
eviction moratorium you can't evict
right if lenders are giving you
forbearance on not paying your debt no
one's gonna be selling anything right
now they don't need to what happens when
that dries up what happens when the bank
goes that that was ten months dawg you
got a cert pain things are gonna start
hitting the market I think and when
things start hitting the market I think
that's when you start seeing price
questions supply and demand right
there's a shortage still that's what we
haven't I think a lot of the sellers
haven't accepted a price correction
because there's still a shortage so what
happens or everything hits market
possible price correction now none of
that could happen this is a full-blown
speculation right but at least how we're
planning for and we underwrite do we
look for deals that what happens if
everything everything goes wrong can we
still hold this asset and if the answer
answer is yes then we move forward on it
and that's always been our strategy so
truthfully it's easier environments for
like this for us than it was last year
like last year everybody looks at us it
goes everybody else is getting higher
returns in you like why would I want to
mess with you and then now they're like
wait you didn't lose investors money and
you guys are still okay now I want to be
with you so that's you know that it
always works that way right is uh is
everything looks great until you realize
that they're taking so much risk that it
actually may not be the smart risk that
you're actually taking everything looks
great when the market is moving up it
makes everybody look like they know what
they're doing
this is what weaves everybody out and
this is where the pros survive and the
amateurs go away and then it happens all
over again
this is cycles yeah I love that look to
wrap up I always ask the same two
questions first one is what is the most
important book that you've ever read the
most important book I've ever read is
the Bible I believe why
the I think well I think there's three
questions that we all have to answer to
to have joy and that's identity purpose
and destiny and the Bible answers all
three so that was the the point in my
life where I went I know who I am I know
why I'm here and I know where I'm going
after this and so that's why I think
it's the most important and another
thing that's real interesting the Bible
talks of as far as the topic goes talks
about money more than anything is such a
it's such a good way on how to live a
life of joy and also people think like I
don't know I think people have an idea
that the Bible is like Santa Claus it's
like a made-up story historically
historically it is a great documentation
of what happened right the argument then
becomes about God or not but I mean dude
there is full of value in that so that I
would say is the most valuable lesson
but it's a great answer I'm going on
that I once had somebody come on the
podcast he's an ancient alien researcher
and he basically said there's two
questions that everyone asked which is
what happens when we die right which I
think the Bible addresses and then are
we here alone
so my second question is more fun which
is aliens believer or non-believer you
ask everybody this question I've asked
over 330 people yeah oh man
the answer is I don't know I'm not sure
I think you're the first person to
answer that way so explain the reason I
say that is
okay so because of my first answer right
Bible doesn't talk about aliens and so
and I believe the Bible to be true and
so that you can either take that one or
two ways there either isn't aliens or
I'm not supposed to know about them and
so I don't know there could be there
could it be I've never seen one so as
far as what my eyes can tell me the
answer would be no I hear about some
crazy stuff that makes it pretty
what would you say convincing that there
could be but I don't know I don't have
an answer do you I think it's
fascinating though yeah oh yeah trust me
and there's some people who got some
wacky theories for sure especially with
this new one you saw this new one that
came up and you don't know if it's true
or not right here in a second I don't
know if that's like a manipulated video
or not but like what the hell was that
look I'll be the first tell you if I
ever see one I will be there real until
then no I'm not gonna that's awesome
you get asked me one question to finish
this up what is the one question you
have for me so you focus on Krypton yeah
what do you know why do you let okay
this might extend our convo for 10
minutes but that's fine it would be
great so what I know from crypto I would
say I'm not completely in the dark but I
am the furthest thing from a beginner I
understand the concept of it I believe
that it's the future I don't believe it
I believe it's gonna have to become
regulated in some sense for to actually
become a true currency that you can
invest in but the concept of it I like
uh to add to that you know I saw this
whole thing with was it doji coin or
something like that trend dogecoin oh
god and crypto combined is dangerous
people can lose a lot of money on this
so I would say
where I'm at right now there's a lack of
experience in education so my answer
this might not be a qualified answer but
for how I invest which is more of a
value based investing I'm not there yet
with crypto de to consider it as that
yet but I think it's the future and I
believe crypto becomes a one world
currency that we all followed by so
here's what's really interesting right
is what you just articulated I actually
think it's one of the most popular
perspectives of Bitcoin / crypto right
some people call crypto sand you will
say just Bitcoin by itself but it's
basically the bitcoin is a coin of
crypto correct yes so this is where it
gets a little bit more controversial in
the crypto community but basically think
about if there's three types of coins
right so there's currencies things that
actually want to operate like digital
money there are digital securities right
so imagine a stock being more of like a
coin type thing so the equity
competitions like that and then in the
middle there's kind of these utility
tokens so a very over-generalized
example would be when you used to go to
Chuck E Cheese you had a coin you can I
play games you got entertainment value
and maybe got some tokens and you could
go like redeem it for a gift or
something to it give you access to
something right same thing would be like
an Amazon gift card could be access to
the Amazon network or whatever and so
Bitcoin is basically the winner when it
comes to the currencies right it's
either bitcoins gonna be the winner or
nothing in terms of replacing the US
dollar or anything like that all these
other tokens can replace certain stocks
they may give you access to networks all
that kind of stuff but to me it's like
those other things or less binary
Bitcoin is very binary either the dollar
gets unseated and Bitcoin is the winner
or we were you know continue on with my
fiat currency type system but what you
said of like hey I know there's
something going on basically like I
don't really understand it but it just
feels like the momentum and energy and
like that is the future I actually think
that's what a lot of people think right
because they're just
the time I don't feel like I'm qualified
to understand all the nuances and even
like teach other people about or
whatever but it just feels like there's
like too many smart people and too much
energy and money and just like the
direction it's heading seems very
similar to like what the internet was in
the mid-90s right it just people being
like yeah like I kind of like I get it
but I don't really use it yet and like
it feels like that's gonna be important
but like other people will figure it out
and so I actually think that's like a
really good thing for crypto in some
weird way right because it's kind of
like people don't have to understand the
nuances but they're buying into this
idea of like decentralization and all of
that and so when it eventually becomes
very user friendly and all that I think
eventually then puberty of course this
was gonna be a thing I said no how or
when like now ready to use it right yeah
and to add to that I mean think about
think about the lack of understanding
when it comes to investments in period
in general most people don't understand
the nuances the stock market they
understand the nuances of real estate
even investing in currencies but they
still do right so but look I'll tell you
revelations last chapter talks about
what happens at the end of this world
right and they're very clear about one
world government one world currency so
you look at this time and you know I
believe it to be true I go okay if there
ends up being one world currency what is
the currency it has to be a digital form
right that's why I think so yeah was he
there I tend to think that everything
points to we end up in a situation where
there's a global curse like Jack Dorsey
from what Twitter and square basically
says like look there's a native currency
for every country but basically the
Internet is its own country you and I
are citizens of the internet right and
so like it needs its own currency so
that one world currency ends up people
whose Bitcoin I believe that right other
people might think of something else but
also what you go to like the
geopolitical stuff like you're telling
me that China Russia the United States
India and like you know 150 other
countries are all gonna keep using their
own currency and doing trade with each
other and trying to guess who's
manipulating whose currency like okay
tell your hand
believing where where uh where can
people find you on the internet and and
find more about the investing stuff okay
so if you want to find me on the
internet Instagram is probably like the
hub it's just my name might be Taylor
you could pretty much find me from there
but all of my other handles are the same
period I'm a tip top trend before they
remove it you know I have a number on my
Instagram that you could text me and
then the investment stuff is commune
capital so you can go to commune capital
calm you know calm unit on Instagram or
you could find it all for my Instagram
awesome
Alyssa man I really appreciate aching
the time to do this I'm super excited
for you guys and all the real estate
question you're doing and let's send
people over there
thanks Anna I appreciate it brother